بايدن يعتبر قرار اصدار الجنائيه الدوليه
مذكره توقيف بحق الرئيس الروسي بوتين مبرر
اشتباكات مسلحه في مدينه مزار شريف بولايه
بلخ الافغانيه بين طالبان وداعش خراسان
والصحافه الصحيفه الرسميه في كوريا
الشماليه تكشف عن تجنيد مئات الالاف جيشها
لقتال الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
نبداها من تداعيات وردود الفعل حول اصدار
مذكره توقيف بحق الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين حيث اعتبر الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
ان قرار الجنائيه الدوليه مبرر
الرئيس الرصيف الذي ارتكب جرائم حرب وقرار
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه باصدار مذكره
توقيف بحقه مبرر
كما علقت الخارجيه الامريكيه على قرار
الجنائيه الدوليه بالقول لا شك ان روسيا
ترتكب جرائم حرب في اوكرانيا ويتعين
محاسبه المسؤولين واضافت الخارجيه ان مدعي
عام الجنائيه دوليه يقوم بدور مستقل واكدت
انها تدعم محاسبه مرتكبي جرائم الحرب
هذا وكان قضاه في المحكمه الجنائيه دوليه
في لاهاي او قاض كان امر باعتقال او اصدر
امرا باعتقال ضد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين على خلفيه الحرب الروسيه في
اوكرانيا متهمين بوتين بارتكاب جرائم حرب
كما اصدر قضاه المحكمه الجنائيه امر
اعتقال ضد مفوضت حقوق الاطفال في روسيا
اصدرت المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه مذكرتي
توقيف بشان اوكرانيا ضد فلاديمير بوتين
الرئيس الروسي وماريا البوبا بلوفا مفوضه
الرئاسه الروسيه لحقوق الطفل بتهم جرائم
الحرب المتمثله في الترحيل القسري للاطفال
من الاراضي الاوكرانيه الى روسيا هذه لحظه
مهمه في عمليه العداله امام المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه لقد راجع القضاه
المعلومات والادله التي قدمها المدعي
العام كريم خان وقرروا ان هناك مزاعم ذات
مصداقيه ضد هؤلاء الاشخاص مرتبطه بالات
همات الموجهه اليهم المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه تقوم بدورها حيث اصدر القضاه
بصفتها محكمه قانونيه مذكرات توقيف وتنفيذ
هذه المذكرات يعتمد على التعاون الدولي
هذا وقال المتحدث الرسمي باسم المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه في تصريح للعربيه ان
مذكره القبض على بوتين ليست حكما
بالمسؤوليه وانا تنفيذ يعتمد على تعاون
الدول المنضمه لنظام روما
المحكمه
بالقبض على مشتبه به فهذا يعني ان القضاه
يعتبرون ان من الضروري ان يمثل امامهم لان
هنالك
ادله تكفي في المرحله التمهيديه للاشتباه
به ولكن هذا ليس حكما بالمسؤوليه الحكم
بالمسؤوليه يكون بعد مرحله محاكمه اذا ما
وصلنا اليها اوامر القبض هي ما يصدره
القضاه ولكن تنفيذ هذه الاوامر كما ذكر
رئيس المحكمه نفسه هذا امل يعتمد على
التعاون الدولي فالدول التي هي منضمه الى
نظام روما عليها واجب قانوني بالتعاون مع
المحكمه والقاء القبض على مجتبر بهم اذا
كانوا متواجدين على اراضيها
اما المدعي العامه السابق للمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه فقال لقناه العربيه ان
المحكمه لديها الصلاحيات لتوجيه الاتهام
للرئيس الروسي معتبرا انه يمكن اعتقاله
لدى وصوله لاي دوله عضو في المحكمه
الجنائيه لكنه اشار الى ان المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه ليس لديها القوه الشرطيه
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه لديها صلاحيه
الكامله بصفتها المحكمه الوحيده في العالم
التي بامكانها توجيه الاتهامات للرئيس
الروسي حيث يمكن اعتقاله لدى وصوله لاي
دوله عضو في المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه لكن
يجب معرفه ان المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
ليس لديها القوه الشرطيه رغم ان القرار
الذي تم اتخاذه هام وسيفتح بابا واسعا
لاداره الصراع الحاصل في اوكرانيا هذا
القرار يمكن ان يستغرق وقتا ولكن سيتم
تنفيذه حتى وان قالت روسيا بانها ليست
عضوا في المحكمه
منظمه العفو دوليه بقرار الجنائيه الدوليه
اصدار مذكره توقيف او اصدار مذكره توقيف
بحق رئيس روسيا على خلفيه ترحيل اطفال
اوكرانيين بشكل غير قانوني واعتبرته خطوه
نحو تحقيق العداله اشادت المنظمه بالمحكمه
بالمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه واعلنت انها
تنتظر محاكمتك كل المسؤولين عن جرائم
الحرب في اوكرانيا
من جانبه قال الكريم ان قرارات المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه باطله وان الاتهامات
التي تلقيها الجنائيه الدوليه غريبه وغير
مقبوله وغير معترف بها في موسكو كما اشارت
الخارجيه الروسيه لانه لا صلاحيات للمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه على موسكو كونها ليست
عضوا فيها معتبره انه لا قيمه لمذكره
المحكمه وانها باطله قانونيا من جهتها
قالت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ان مذكره
الاعتقال بحق بوتين ما هي الا البدايه
الرئيس الاوكراني في اشاد بقرار المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه باصدار مذكره توقيف بحق
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير ووصفه بانه قرار
تاريخي
اصدرت المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه مذكره
توقيف بحق بوتين وهو قرار تاريخي تبدا منه
المسؤوليه التاريخيه بوتين اصبح رئيس
الدوله الارهابيه ومسؤولونروس اخرون مشتبه
بهم رسميا في جريمه حرب
اعلن رئيس الوزراء السلوفاكيا ادوارد ان
الحكومه سلوفاكيا وافقت على ارسال طائرات
مقاتله من طراز مج 29 الى اوكرانيا مما
زاد من مساعدتها العسكريه نتعرف الى
المشاهدين على هذه المقاتله في هذا العرض
طائره مقاتله من الجيل الرابع
مصممه بمقعد واحد او مقعدين ولها محركان
يعتقد انها نظيره المقاتله الامريكيه اف
يمكنها حمل قنابل يصل وزنها الى ثلاثه
الاف كيلو جرام
[موسيقى]
تعرف ايضا بقدرتها على حمل ست قنابل نوويه
صممت للسيطره الجويه ابانا اوج قوه
الاتحاد السوفيتي
عام
1983 دخلت الخدمه في سلاح الجو السوفيتي
لا تزال في الخدمه في العشرات من دول
العالم
تشهد مدينه مزار شريف في ولايه بلغ شمالي
افغانستان اشتباكات مسلحه قويه بين قوات
طالبان ومسلحين مجهولين منذ عده ساعات
وحتى الان وقالت مصادر محليه ان الهجوم
شنت واستخبارات طالبان على مخبا لتنظيم
داعش خراسا
يخوض تنظيم داعش وجماعه بوكو حرام ابرز
مجموعتين متشددتين متشددتين عفوا في
نيجيريا يخوضان حربا مستعره شمال البلاد
في محاوله كل طرف السيطره على تلك المنطقه
والتي تتمتع جماعه بوكو حرامي المتشدده
بنفوذ كبير فيها منذ نشاتها قبل نحو 14
عاما
التنافس على منطقه الشمال النيجيري يشعل
حربا غير مسبوقه بين تنظيم داعش وجماعه
بوكو حرام دويل انفجارات القويه واطلاق
الرصاص يتواصلان ويزدادان كثافه مع ساعات
الليل بين ابرز جمعتين متطرفين في نيجيريا
جوله القتال الحديثه بدات منذ اسابيع
باقتحام مقاتلين من بوكو حرام معسكرات
لداعش غربي افريقيا حينها اطلق ابو بكر
قناي احد كبار قاده بوكو حرام هجوما على
جزيرتين ليسيطر عليه
واجبره على التراجع قبل ان يقتحم سجنا
ويفرج عن العديد من المعتقلين والرهائن
ومن بعيد فهناك من ينظر للقتال بعين الرضا
فالاستخبارات النيجيريه تراقب ما يحدث بين
الجمعتين المتطرفين
وتطوراته من الصعب اعطاء حصيله تشمل
الجانبين لكن الارقام هائله نتحدث عن اكثر
من 200 قتيل فقط في جمعه تورو قرب الحدود
مع النيجر حرب الهيمنه على حوض بحيرات
تشاد ومحيطه التي يخوضها حلفاء سابقون
حصدت ارواح اكثر من 200 عنصر من جماعه
بوكو حرام نهايه الشهر الماضي حروب
التنافس التي تدور بين الجماعتين كان
سبقها تحالف وثيق فتنظيم داعش الخصم
المرير لبوكو حرام كان جزءا من الجماعه
المتشدده قبل انشقاقه منذ سنوات ليخوض
الجانبان معارك ضد بعضهما وضد القوات
المسلحه النيجيريه حنان المصري العربيه
قال رئيس النظام السوري بشار الاسد ان
بلاده قد تصل الى حوار مع تركي على مستوى
وزراء الخارجيه لكن هذا يعتمد على تفاصيل
الحوار بين دمشق وانقره وحول امكانيه
الحوار مع الجانب التركي نقله الرئاسه
السوريه عن الاسد قوله ان دمشق بدات
المفاوضات على المستوى الامني وعلى مستوى
وزراء الدفاع وكانت الرئاسه التركيه اشارت
في وقت سابق الا ان شروط الاسد للقاء
اردوغان غير مناسبه لتطبيع العلاقات بين
البلدين
الجفاف وانخفاض منسوب المياه ازمه تلقي
بظلالها وتبعاتها على العراق وسوريا
وسببها بناء السدود من قبل ايران وتركيا
مما اوقع سوريا والعراق بين فكيك ما شاء
الازمه هددت الزراعه في البلدين وانذرت
بمستقبل يهدده الجفاف المياه الوارده من
تركيا عبر نهري الفرات والدجله انحسرت
اكثر من النصف منذ اكثر من ثلاثه اعوام
هذه المشكله تلقي بتداعياتها السلبيه على
السكان المحليين في كل هذه المنطقه
على الفرات العظيم توقف سد التشرين ابرز
السدود عن انتاج الكهرباء اسبوعا كاملا
كمقدمه لازمه شامله تهدد قطاعات الكهرباء
ومياه الري والزراعه التي يستفيد منها
اكثر من مليون سوري بينما على دجله وضع
الضحاره النهر امال الفلاحين ومستقبلهم
على المحك يعني
السدود التي اقامتها تركيا على دجله دمرت
النهر مياهه اصبحت اسنه ورائحته كريهه ولم
تعد صالحه للشرب ولا للزراعه حتى صيد
الاسماك تراجع
حرب مياه تقودها تركيا بصمت سبق وان حذر
مسؤولون اكراد من انها قد تؤدي الى كارثه
في سوريا تمتد بطبيعه الحال الى العراق لا
يختلف الوضع هنا كثيرا عن سوريا فاكثر من
اربعين نهرا ومجرا مائيا مشتركا قطع تها
ايران عن العراق بينما خلصت تركيا حصص
العراق المائيه من نهري دجله والفرات الى
اقل من 60%
المياه والجفاف اضر كثيرا بقطاع الزراعه
في العراق ابو محمد احد المزارعين الذين
توقفوا عن الزراعه بسبب عدم توفر المياه
للري وهذا الامر ينسحب على بقيه المزارعين
في بلاد الرافدين الذين هاجر معظمهم
اراضيهم الزراعيه العالم اضطرت ان تبيع
بساتين
ها وذراعي فعلا نطالب وطالبنا مدير
الزراعه وطالبنا لجان مختصه وماكو حلول
لحد الان هسه مدير الزراعه يقول الخطه سنه
نص بنص يعني قبل الخطه كانت كامله والفلاح
ويعاني فكيف هذه الصناعه نص ابن نص يعني
الفلاح راح يتدهور
ايران بنت اكثر من 123 سدا كبيرا ومتوسطا
وصغيرا على الانهار التي تسب داخل الاراضي
العراقيه بينما بنت تركيا 500 سدا مماثلا
على نهر دجله والفرات هذا الامر سيؤدي
بحسب الخبراء الى جفاف هذه الانهار
مستقبلا من بغداد منتظر الرشيد العربيه
نشرتنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد قليل
اصلاح نظام التقاعد يشعل فرنسا
بالاحتجاجات واشتباكات الليليه بين الشرطه
والمتظاهرين في باريس
اهلا بكم من جديد
عين رئيس تونسي قيس سعيد والي تونس كمال
الفقي الذي يعتبر احد الشد مناصري الرئيس
عينه وزيرا لداخليه واتى تعيين كمال الفقه
بعد ساعه قليله من اعلان توفيق شرف الدين
تنحيه من منصبه بعد نحو عامين على اشرافه
على الوزاره مرجعا سبب الاستقاله لدواء
شخصيه
كبير جدا بان
[موسيقى]
اخذ عن نفسي مسؤوليه وزاره الداخليه لانه
هناك امانه اخرى نادتني الامانه الامانات
تونس امانه وطننا امانه امننا امانه
ابتسامه الطفل في المهدي امانه
احلام الشباب التي ضاعت البحر امانه
انتظارات الام لابنائها ابانا المصدح امام
الاعلامي امانه
اشتبكت شرطه مكافحه الشغب الفرنسيه مع
متظاهرين في باريس حيث خرجت مظاهره جديده
ضد قرار الحكومه رفع سن التقاعد في البلاد
واستخدمت الشرطه الغاز المسيل الدموع
للتعامل مع اضطراب الحشود
وبينما تجمع المتظاهرون في ساحه الكونكورد
بتاريس بالقرب من المبنى البرلمان
اجواء تراقب وحذر تعيشها العاصمه الفرنسيه
باريس دعوات عشوائيه للتظاهر يستجيب لها
الطلاب وتحشد لها الشرطه قواتها امام مقر
البرلمان
مستفيدين من ورشات صيانه في ساحه
الكونكورد امام البرلمان صنع المتظاهرون
حواجزهم ووضعوها امام الشرطه هدفوا لاسقاط
الرئيس وغنوا باجواء احتفاليه اشعل
النيران وغذو لهيبها ثم القوا ماكرون مجسم
بداخلها
دقائق قليله وتبدا المعركه ازدياد اعداد
المتظاهرين وبلوغها 4000 شخص دفع الشرطه
لفض التظاهر بالقوه رشقات حجاره ومقذوفات
من المتظاهرين الذين نحتلوا الساحه لخمس
ساعات ردت عليها الشرطه بالقنابل المسيله
للدموع حتى تمكنت من عزلهم وتقسيمهم الى
مجموعات
ومحاصره كل واحده على حده فاجبرتهم على
المغادره عنوه وكذلك فعلت مع وسائل
الاعلام التي رافقتها عناصر الشرطه للتاكد
من مغادرتها استعاده الشرطه سيطرتها على
الوضع في الميدان مثلا انتصارا صغيرا
لمعركه انتهت اليوم في الشارع وستبدا
الاسبوع المقبل في البرلمان مع اعلان حزب
التجمع الوطني من اقصى اليمين بزعامه مال
لوبان طرح اول مذكره حجب للثقه عن الحكومه
لقد قمنا بطرح مذكره حجب الثقه عن الحكومه
ايضا سنقوم بالتصويت على اي مذكره حجب ثقه
اخرى تطرح من اجل اسقاط الحكومه مذكره
اقصى اليمين لم تكن الوحيده اذ اعلنت كتله
النواب المستقلين طرح مذكره من جهتها
ستصوت عليها قوى اليسار الخمس في البرلمان
مجتمعه
سيكون من المفيد لدينا نصوت على مذكره حجب
الثقه لاسقاط قانون رفع سن التقاعد غير
العادل وغير المفيد ذلك سيكون من اجل حفظ
الديمقراطي البرلمانيه والاجتماعيه
والى ان يجتمع البرلمان مجددا يوم الاثنين
المقبل للتصويت على مذكرتي حجم الثقه
ستخيم على شوارع العاصمه مشاهد انتشار
قوات الامن خوفا من امتداد رقعه الحريق
الذي اشعله الرئيس الى كل المدن الفرنسيه
على ما تقول المعارضه
فدهوك العربيه باريس
صحيفه الرسميه في كوريا الشماليه ان مئات
الالاف من المواطنين في البلاد تطوعوا
للانضمام الى جيشها او اعاده تجنيدهم
للقتال ضد الولايات المتحده وافادت صحيفه
رودونس سينا
الرسميه بان حوالي
حوالي 800 الف من الطلاب والعاملين في
البلاد تطوعوا للانضمام الى جيشها او
اعاده تجنيدهم للقتال ضد الولايات المتحده
في مصر يعد الغلاء عاملا مؤثرا على نمط
الاستهلاك في رمضان حيث نفذت الحكومه
محاولات لعرض سلع باسعار منخفضه في معارض
اقيمت خصيصا لهذا الغرض لكن مع ذلك سيضطر
غالبيه المستهلكين لتخفيض الكميات التي
يشترونها او تغيير نمط استهلاكهم لسلع
بعينها
[تصفيق]
ترتفع معدلات الاستهلاك كل عام في رمضان
رصدنا هذا اكثر من مره ملايين من المصريين
يتوجهون الى معارض مثل هذا المعرض معرض
اهلا رمضان وهو بالمناسبه منتشر في جميع
انحاء مصر يبحثون عن سلعه مخفضه فهل
بالفعل يجدون ضالتهم في مثل هذه الاماكن
ام يضطرون بسبب موجات الغلاء المتلاحقه
الى تخفيض معدلات الاستهلاك ابراهيم قاسم
يعمل في مصرف ولم تسبق له زياره معارض
السلع المخفضه من قبل ولهذا السبب وجدناهم
متابعا جيدا للاسعار في السوق ويعقد
المقارنات اينما صار
انا اول مره اخش النهارده بس جميله اللحمه
ماشي اللحمه دلوقتي المتين متين وحاجه انا
اما اجيب على قد انا ولادي باللحمه برده
هنا ممكن يقول لك دي ب 120 الكفته زي ما
انت علبه التونه ب 20 جنيه هم بره بيبيعوه
بتلاتين جنيه وهو دي حلوه بره مصر كلها
ستصوم خلال الفتره القادمه بمسلميها في
شهر رمضان ومسيحييها الذين يصومون الصوم
الكبير او الاربعيني في نفس الوقت تقريبا
لذلك وجدنا مجدي اسحاق ومجدي وديع يتسوقان
من معرض اهلا رمضان اكيد طبعا حضرتك كل
واحد له ميزانيه والميزانيه بدل ما اشتري
حاجه هشتري عشره منها فطبعا لازم اقلل من
الاستراك واشتري خمسه انا في بيتي كنت
بجيب مكرونه من اللي هي الغاليه مش هقول
طبعا عشان الدعايه وكده النهارده بجيب نفس
المكرونه بس مش سيمولينا بجيبها دي عادي
حاجه بتتقضى يعني حاجه بديل لحاجه يعني
الحالم مشابه في الاسواق الشعبيه حيث
يحاول يستهلكون تغيير عاداتهم الغذائيه من
خلال البدائل المتوفره وبعضهم لا يرى جدوى
من الذهاب للمعارض ما لم تكن قريبه لا نحن
ولا فراخ من ساعه الغنم انا دلوقتي شوف
اللحمه بكام دلوقتي نزلت اهلا رمضان وشفت
الاسعار هي الاسعار مخفضه بس مش قوي يعني
بالنسبه لبره هي احسن كل تاجر بحط سعر
بطريقه جنونيه لدرجه ان ممكن تلاقي السلعه
باكثر من ساعه هذا الامر دفع بشركات
المملوكه للدوله واجهات سياديه للعب دور
في توفير سلع ارخص في محاوله لضبط الاسواق
لو ما نزلتش انا بكميات وبسعر منافس هتجد
ان الاسعار ممكن تعلق لسبب مش هنوقف حرس
على كل بيان السلع ومتوفره في الاسواق
لناحيه الكميات وخاصه بعد حل مشكلات تتعلق
بالاستيراد وتوفير العمله ولكن تظلوا
الاسعار هي الفيصل بالنسبه للمستهلكين
تامر نصره العربيه القاهره
بعدما اتخذت الاتجاهات الديموغرافيه مسارا
مختلفا في العالم بالسنوات ثلاث الماضيه
وانطلاقا من فكره جلب قوه عامله تحل مشكله
النقص المستمر في العماله ولد مشروع تقني
في شركه قامت بتجميع فريق من اربعين شخصا
جميعهم خبراء في مجال تكنولوجيا
والروبوتات لتصميم روبوتات شبيهه بالبشر
يمشون ويقفزون وقد يتوجهون الى مكان العمل
بدلا عنك قريبا عيون تراقب وتتحرك يدان
وقدمان جسم ليس بغريب عن العين البشريه
لكنهم ليسوا بشرا بل من صنع اياديهم
اشكالهم مختلفه ووظائفهم متعدده روبوتات
شبيهه بالبشر قد تحل مشكله نقص العماله
شركه تعمل على مشروع تقني هدفه تصميم
روبوتات شبيهه بالشكل البشري روحه الذكاء
الاصطناعي النموذج الاولي للروبوت سيكون
قادرا على المشي وتسلق السلالم وفتح
الابواب واستخدام الادوات وصناديق الرفع
وربما حتى اعداد العشاء اما في تفاصيل
التنفيذ فالشركه تخطط لانشاء مستودع وهمي
لاختبار نموذجهم الاولي الذي سيكون
كهربائيا بالكامل ويعمل لمده خمس ساعات
لكن عقبات قد تقف في طريق الخبراء اذ ان
الروبوتات الشبيهه بالبشر من الصعب جدا
بناؤها وهندستها لاداء موثوق به
التصميم سيستغرق عقودا حتى تتمكن
الروبوتات من تكرار الاشياء المعقده التي
يمكن الاجسامنا القيام بها لكن الحالمين
يبذلون قصار جهدهم في محاوله لتحقيق ذلك
يعتبر قرار اصدار الجنائيه الدوليه مذكره
توقيف بحق الرئيس الروسي بوتين مبرر
اشتباكات مسلحه في مدينه مزهر الشريف
بولايه بلخ الافغانيه بين طالبان وداعش
خراسان
وصحيفه الرسميه في كوريا الشماليه تكشف عن
تجنيد مئات الالاف في جيشها لقتال
الولايات المتحده
دائما العربيه مشاهدينا لمزيد من المتابعه
القاكم بعد دقائق في نشره اخرى الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]